ragazzi golf simulator navi 3 alena
vieni quanti ne vai o eccolo trovato la
mia donna ho trovato la mia donna vieni
qui vieni qua mangia quello che ti dal
tuo uomo brava il prossimo passo è
quello di chiedere di andare a letto
insieme tesoro bella io lo so che tu mi
ami lo vedo dal tuo sguardo che mi ami
street e le cibo una donna le vi amerà
per sempre un caso della vita è una
legge nomis e mia quella donna lì e non
è che dava in groppa turno si è bella ma
vai un saluto privi dai bastard e ma
forte lo spingere capre dal mio amico
laggiù è mai chiesto di farlo io la
stessa società
[Musica]
ciao ragazzi a parigi l'hotel a tutti i
ragazzi a tutti i ragazzi a vigenti
bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video per a tutti ragazzi e
benvenuto a questo video sono davanti ma
vige ancora la mia faccia in blocchi è
bello e tutti ragazzi e prendermi da
questo video sono fa vj poi oggi siamo
in un uomo prima di cominciare ragazzi
cosa ed è ripartire con fucka della
settimana che questa settimana è stata
vinta da award che ha fatto questa roba
che una roba che roba guarda quanto
siamo figli guarda che ignoti guarda che
roba
cioè ti rendi co siamo noi guarda che in
gioco che t'hanno fatto io sono rimasto
esterrefatto da questa è una delle più
belle che abbia mai ricevuto di fan
altri grazie di cuore dovesse ragazzini
passare le news la prima news che domani
parto non sono più in marocco tornerò a
casa grazie a dio per niente vivo vivo
qua da un troppo
marocchino ormai e quindi tornare a casa
mi sembra previti quasi un sogno non si
vede che sto tornando a casa è giusto un
po in disordine camera mia
torno a casa e ci sto cinque giorni più
o meno poi riparto per los angeles stati
circa cinque giorni quindi sembravate
affezionati a questo scenario mi
dispiace però sollevando le tende nel
vero senso della parola
la vacca viene giù
credo che fosse la battuta più triste
che io abbiamo infatti in tutta la mia
vita ma stando alla seconda news ragazzi
è uscito il mio libro alla fine è stata
una cosa epocale perché mi sono arrivate
foto da tutti quanti non avete mandato
che l'avete preso spero vi piaccia io
non ho più nient'altro da dirvi ragazzi
grazie di cuore veramente grazie non ho
più niente da dire sono contentissimo e
nulla altro fatto la foto con l'asino
che andava a prenderlo anch'io col
destriero guardami che figo che son ora
non sono quello quello che so è che
cazzo quindi ragazzi se come me ne sto
per andare da questa incredibile posto
che alla fine mi ci sono affezionato ho
voluto fare un mini montaggio di momenti
epici che fa che ho vissuto in queste
tre settimane qui niente ragazzi mi
lascio al video sarà alquanto strano ve
lo garantisco
[Musica]
bene
soldi sopra una macchina
[Applauso]
tra gli amici per un attimo bello riga
quella macchina lì non so che cosa cazzo
sta anche questo
avete presente che cosa significa avere
un insetto della madonna in camera ecco
a me fanno abbastanza schifo quindi ho
dovuto chiamare i rinforzi per ucciderlo
e guardate voi stessi
[Risate]
che schifo è morta e malandate e siccome
non era morta manco per il cazzo dovuto
chiamare altri rinforzi che grazie a te
come ho fatto a non morire che vede la
schiacciata manco fosse hulk ma perché
no dai non lo posso fare arrivati sino
sismi fa schifo a greca
guarda che un mix e magari pure degli
amici america già tutto giù uno guarda
se voleva la lega non vede disposta dai
post a porta a porta che schifo se su 20
leila io adesso siamo
via ma aliev oppure quelle volte in cui
ti perdi nel deserto c'è una macchina se
la macchia ragazzo si è un problema
non so guidare
tanto io so come si fa perché ho avuto
degli istruttori in grado di insegnarmi
tipo trovo un gta sempre l'area ci prova
dai prima col cazzo succede adesso si è
accesa ce la posso fare ragazzi ci siamo
devo tornare alla civiltà comprendere
come il pedale permette giu davanti c'è
una non vedo un cazzo cioè della civiltà
eravamo a due metri però non importa noi
non so preso una macchina adesso
l'avevano rubata e vado all apporto la
porto a casa
quindi ragazzi questa è stata la mia
esperienza in marocco è stato funestato
e niente ragazzi aspettiamo los angeles
lo aspetto proprio ho paura di quello
che succederà quando sarò lì e quindi
ragazzi passiamo al fa vi risponde che è
meglio in questo caso mai risponde favi
per una volta una domanda seria o mio
dio quando tu avrai una famiglia tu a
cui pensare continuerai a rimetterci
dritto alla giornata con il tuo umorismo
allora è una bella domanda in realtà non
vedo perché non debba fare qualcosa di
divertente io cerco sempre di fare il
deficente questo sicuro sui videogames
penso di sì perché comunque sono un
videogioco sono nato coi videogiochi
nella pancia di mia madre ho già game
boy e magari trasmetterò questa roba mio
figlio farà lui fa vj 2
spero di no povero cristiano perché
sarah non è così semplice come sembra
quindi va beh non lo so
sono una persona timida e non so se si
sta vedendo mentre racconto di cose
future passiamo alla prossima domanda
che mail ma tanto si parla di anni cioè
tipo esplodere al sole prima perché è
normale moriremo tutti giorlando come
giorlando del no chiamano gior
orlando come ha fatto ad andare in
libreria se stai marò alla nostra cosa
ragazzi incredibile molti mi hanno detto
ma fa io come fatto andare in libreria
se sei in marocco ma se lo vendono in
tutte le librerie d'italia ma secondo me
non lo vendono in marocco il mio libro
facciamo una pro 12 ore per ora una
carta di libreria che poi è una libreria
molto al coperto vabbè minchia ho
trovato twilight che in arabo si dice
dalla mi piace poi line
mi piace per come frate sei libero di
con i sei per caso
dai uscito ieri sotto le cuffie cioè la
stella molto più pensavo peggio
noi invece abbiamo libro non l'avevo
mica visto sotto hitler make up perfetto
c'era anche vicino a a borat è veramente
figo
questo vale estivo da autori importanti
di narrativa italiana pirandello di
narrativa italiana alla pirandello dante
che è la vj abbiamo preso libro di fa vj
in una libreria marrakech e vigo ghiaia
bubu i nomi più intelligenti della terra
ai torti point orali dono scusa zio non
volevo giuro ha posto a posto tutti
ragazzi possiamo la famiglia mandalà
fare domanda di oggi è sì come vada los
angeles tra pochissimo e quindi ci
saranno le zone di gta uguali
praticamente dove volete che vada a fare
un blog di preciso di zona che è uguale
a gta tible molo se cosa dite però è
sarà fatto promesso look great job i
blog spero che vi sia piaciuto il
marocco per quanto lo abbiate visto
nella mia stanza vi saluta anche la che
è stato qua tutto questo tempo a vedermi
dormire di allora che ti sei smanettato
mentre mi vedevi dormire brutto se
grilletto classico quello che vi do
spero come assetto che vi sia piaciuto è
causato video che quante volte detto
video negli ultimi tre secondi 12 più
bene cosa ed ragazzi sia il video che
non avevo ancora detto vi è piaciuto al
sotto commento mi piace anche la pagina
di facebook e come lo divido tra una
descrizione sedersi dischi alcuni cibi e
ora prossimo visto belle ragazze
[Musica]